do you regret you know because I
remember very vividly you were waving
the little pump flag harder than any
rapper I think I've ever seen you wave a
flag for at a certain point in time I
think I remember when you first went on
The Breakfast Club
on The Breakfast Club you didn't no ever
no well there was an interview
was it just you and Charlemagne I
interviewed him at one point yeah and I
went on the brilliant idiots one time it
was brilliant idiots it was brilliant
idiots okay yeah so when you went on
brilliant idiots I think I remember you
kind of [__] on Rick Ross a little
uh I think they asked me what I thought
of the new Rick Ross album and you were
like I don't [__] care I'm listening
to a little pump or some [__] yeah I
mean that's just really there's just
artists who I like and then at a certain
point once they're on like album Number
Eight I'm just not well I was gonna say
there was like you were kind of like
partially the face of like that
SoundCloud era and you were also very
anti
uh a lot of the other [__] I think I got
a lot of the the a lot of that
reputation for being like
anti-traditional hip-hop just because of
the fact that I was like the adult in
the room when Lil pump and smoke prep
were chanting [__] J Cole even though I
don't think I ever I don't think I ever
said [__] J Cole you know like I I was
not invested in it like that and I've
always been able to appreciate you know
more traditional hip-hop and everything
but yeah I mean that was just I was
around the SoundCloud wave like before
them I was around all these like sesh
Hollow Waterboys dudes and like all the
GBC [__] and then I you know I met I met
Lil pump at a show in Florida that like
ski mask played and like a few other
people and yeah we just hit it up hit it
off on some cool [__] we went on that
tour together and then I you know I went
to a few of his shows after that and
stuff but yeah I mean sometimes when I
think back on that I'm like you're a
grown ass man just really hanging out
with like a 16 year old I was gonna say
you you you in in like fast forward you
have gotten a lot of recent criticism
for maybe that tour and like maybe some
of the stuff that went down on the tour
of pump do you regret any of that tour
or do you think any of that criticism
criticism is fair I mean we were just
hanging out doing zams and like I mean
yeah there's a lot of stuff listen in
retrospect a grown man doing zans with a
child is kind of crazy yeah but that was
just like my little homie at the time
like I didn't I I never thought of it
like that because for sure I've been a
BMX dude my whole life and I've been
getting you know smoking weed and
drinking and hanging out at the skate
park and yeah all this [__] and I never
had any like level of scrutiny of what I
was doing so it never really occurred to
me and it's not like I was like getting
drugs for them it's like right no like
they had drugs and like sometimes pump
or smoke prep would like hand me a Xanax
and or pour me some lean and I'm like
okay sure yeah you know what would be
your uh thoughts on why you think those
two guys did not live up to their
potential and I guess quote unquote fell
off because I mean it looked like smoke
purp was with Travis and pump was the
biggest guy on the [__] planet you
know I mean part of me you know I got no
ill will towards either of them I still
think that they both potentially you
know have it in them but I feel like
everyone's one hit away that's what I'm
saying like and at a certain point the
Lil pump thing was just so big that it's
like they the people couldn't help but
turn against him at a certain point once
like they loved the meme they loved the
idea of him they loved the the hilarity
of of Pomp and then at a certain point
they just turned away from him because
maybe the music didn't evolve or keep
changing or whatever and uh I don't know
I mean you see it happen on people all
the time like it happened to the baby
they're doing it's a little baby right
now but guess what the baby caught a
record and it's kind of back a little I
I I don't doubt for a minute that the
yeah because he's a smart older guy who
really like has studied the music game
for a long time and that's why I don't
count Lil pump or perp out because I
feel like I think all they need to do is
just like come up with a sound make a
project that encompasses that sound and
all of a sudden those same people that
are hating on them will be like those so
those same people are always trying to
catch a wave or like figure out
something new or different to be into
will be like actually this little pump
album's really good and then that'll be
the meme and I mean they just did it
with Lil yachty when he put out the
[__] Tame Impala type album exactly
and or but like bro you see the way that
they're trying to take little baby down
right now yeah because he put out a
record they hate the record they hated
his last album whatever and so and then
the tour dates are getting canceled and
now they're looking for any little thing
that they can use to put together the
narrative that little baby is a loser
even though a little baby like probably
literally has like you know 50 million
dollars or 100 million dollars or some
[__] like he's living a great life if
anything like I saw ack posted a clip of
like baby make in that song in the
studio and there's all these homies in
the in the studio and they're all
nodding their head and like acting like
they're really into it and then that
song comes out and Twitter just
immediately declares that the worst song
ever and but that's what it's like to be
a superstar is that nobody wants to tell
you that your [__] sucks and you just
are running around the world picking up
you know fifty thousand dollars for a
show a hundred thousand dollars for a
show and then all of a sudden you put
out a song and you just get this reality
check that like oh there's a lot of
people that are not already decided on
the fact that they love you and they're
gonna [__] on you and they're gonna hate
you and you know but somebody like
little baby like I would say the same
thing as pump and purp like
well maybe you'll be fine he just gotta
refocus yeah yeah a little baby's gonna
be all right